ما لا يقل عن 100 قتيل و 400 مصاب نتيجه
هجوم بغازات سامه على مناطق سكنيه في بلده
خان شيخون في ريف ادلب مراسل الجزيره هناك
فادا ان بين القتلى نحو 30 من النساء
والاطفال وان الغازات السامه التي اختنق
بها الضحايا حملتها الصواريخ القتها
طائرات حربيه على البلده في وقت مبكر من
صباح
الثلاثاء سجل النظام السوري في مجال
استخدام الاسلحه الكيميائيه حافل جدا فقد
استخدمها في الغوطه الشرقيه صيف عام
2013 وتزايد استخدامه لها في الايام
القليله الماضيه اي دلاله لهذا التمادي في
استخدام الاسلحه المحظوره وهل تدفع فداحه
المجزره المجتمع الدولي للخروج عن صمته
اخيرا نتابع اولا تقرير نسيبه
موسى عايزين تفسه
تفسه لش تلاحقه بسياره اسعاف يا
شيخ كانهم
نيام من جديد تتكرر الفاجعه ثلاث سنوات
مرت على مجزره الغطه الشرقيه وها هم اطفال
خان شيخون ينامون بصمت نومتهم الاخيره
تكاد تتطابق فصول مجزره خان شيخون بريف
ادلب مع ما جرى في الغوطه الشرقيه بريف
دمشق في اب اغسطس 2013
عند ساعات الصباح الاولى تدك طائرات حربيه
الاحياء السكنيه بصواريخ محمله بغازات
سامه سقط عشرات الضحايا غالبيتهم نساء
واطفال بل ان عائلات باكملها قضت جراء
القصف قتل كل هؤلاء بلا نقطه دم واحده
يؤكد اطباء ميدانيون ومسعفون ان المصابين
عانوا الاعراض ذاتها اغماء وضيق في التنفس
تقيؤ وخروج زبد من الفم علامات يعتبرها
خبراء دليلا على ان المدينه استهدفت بغاز
الاعصاب السارين تضع هذه القرائن النظام
السوري وروسيا في دائره الاتهام لانهما
المسيطر على اجواء المدن السوريه لكن
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه نات بنفسها عن هذه
الشبهات ونفت ان تكون مقاتلاتها قد نفذت
اي غارات على ريف ادلب خلال الساعات
الماضيه شن نظام دمشق هجمات باسلحه
كيميائيه انتهاك للقرار الدولي
218 الذي تبناه مجلس الامن ردا على مجزره
الغوطه الشرقيه ما يستدعي وفق القرار عقد
اجتماع طارئ واتخاذ تدابير ضد نظام الاسد
وفق الفصل السابع من ميثاق الامم المتحده
الذي يجيز التدخل العسكري لكن وعلى الرغم
من الاجراءات الصارمه التي يفرضها خرق
النظام السوري لمعاهده حظر الاسلحه
الكيميائيه فان ردود الفعل الدوليه جاءت
باهته ما بين الوعيد والقلق دون ان ترقى
الى هول ما اقترف في خان شيخون فقد دعت كل
من فرنسا وبريطانيا المعارضه السوريه الى
اجتماع طارئ لمجلس الامن الدولي وقالت
المعارضه ان الهجوم الكيميائي يضع محادثات
جنيف في مهب الريح وحمل الاتحاد الاوروبي
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد المسؤوليه
الرئيسيه عن المجزره اما انقره فوصفت
الحادثه بانها جريمه ضد الانسانيه واكدت
مصادر في الرئاسه التركيه ان الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان بحث الامر في اتصال هاتفي مع
نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين والحقيقه
التي لا ريب فيها ان العداله الجنائيه
الدوليه لا يمكن تحريكها الا بقرار سياسي
وان اروقه مجلس الامن هي الممر الالزامي
لاجراءات راضعه ضد النظام السوري خطوات
كان الفيتو الروسي على الدوام لها
بالمرصاد فدعم موسكو العسكري والسياسي
بمثابه الرئه التي يتنفس بها نظام دمشق
وتمنحه البقاء ومع اداره دونالد ترامب راح
النظام يعول على تبادل الموقف الامريكي
الذي يرى ان رحيل الاسد لم يعد يمثل
اولويه لتسويه الازمه السوريه بل ان
الرئيس الامريكي لا يستبعد التعاون بين
واشنطن ونظام دمشق لقتال ما توصف
بالجماعات
الارهابيه لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من مدينه وينزر في كندا جون سيرون استاذ
القانون الدولي في جامعه وينزر ومن غازي
عنتاب دكتور مازر كواره المدير الاقليمي
للجمعيه الطبيه السوريه الامريكيه سامز
والبدايه
مع مراسلنا من نيويورك مراد هاشم
مراد ما هي ابرز المواقف المعلنه حتى الان
عشيه جلسه مجلس الامن وخاصه الامريكيه
منها نعم جمال مواقف عديده بالاصح كان
اخرها الصادر عن الرئيس دونالد ترامب
والذي اعتبر ان الهجوم مروع وشنيع ومرفوض
من من قبل العالم المتحضر لكنه القى
باللائمة
دعاى فيه ايضا اي تركسون
تركسون ايران
وروسيا باعتبارهما حلفاء النظام وراعيا
مفاوضات ايتانا للضغط على نظام الاسد لوقف
هذه الهجمات وعدم تكرارها واستخدم ايضا
لغه اكثر صرامه ازاء النظام بشار الاسد
فيما يتعلق بهذا الامر في كل الاحوال بدات
اللغه
وا اكثر ليونه مقارنه بما كان مستخدم في
ظل الاداره
السابقه سمعنا هنا في الامم المتحده ايضا
تصريحات من
السفيري بريطانيا وفرنسا كانت بالفعل
شديده اللهجه وكانت صريحه فيما يتعلق
بضروره المحاسبه من قبل مجلس الامن الدولي
وللعلم جمال جلسه غد هي جلسه خطابات ليس
الا اي انها لن تتخذ اي
اجراء ومع ذلك بدات روسيا غير متحمسه
لعقدها بشكل طارئ وبشكل مفتوح كما دعت
بريطانيا وفرنسا ووافقت على ذلك الولايات
المتحده باعتبارها باعتبار انها تراس مجلس
الامن الدولي لم حتى الان لم يتضح ما اذا
كان سيعقب هذه الجلسه بالفعل دعوه وتحرك
باتجاه المحاسبه على الارجح سوف تدفع
روسيا باتجاه مزيد من
التحقيقات جمع المعلومات حول هذه الحادثه
لمعرفه من يقف وراءها ولكن كما نعلم جمال
كان كانت روسيا والصين
عرقلت قرار مشروع قرار قدم في نهايه
فبراير الماضي وكان يفرض عقوبات مخففه الى
در
سمعناه مندوبه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تقول بان هذه الجلسه ستكون علنيه ومفتوحه
يعني ما الذي سيحدث غدا هل ستكون هناك
جلسه هل سيكون يكون هناك قرار هل ستكون
هناك تصويت مثلا اتخاذ قرارات
حاسمه في الواقع جمال كما اشرت هي جلسه
خطابات
ولكن لكونها مفتوحه واصرار الدول الغربيه
تحديدا فرنسا وبريطانيا والولايات المتحده
على ان تكون مفتوحه هي وسيله من وسائل
الضغط على روسيا واحراجها بشكل اكبر
واظهارها في موقف المدافع عن جرائم النظام
بشر
الاسد وهو ما كانت روسيا تحاول تجنبه عبر
الدفع بان تكون هذه الجلسه بان تناقش بان
يناقش هذا الهجوم في اطار الجلسه الدوريه
الاعتياديه الخاصه بالاسلحه بالسلاح
باستخدام السلاح الكيميائي في سوريا والتي
كانت مقرره في الواقع يوم غد ولكن مساء اي
ان الفارق بين
الجلستين بضعه ساعات لكن الان هذه الجلسه
الان ستعقد بشكل طارئ غدا صباحا بالتوقيت
المحلي لنيويورك وجلسه مفتوحه على لا حديث
حتى الان ما اذا كان سيعقبها اي تحرك
باتجاه الدفع بقرار بمشروع قرار جديد
لمعاقبه النظام السوري لكن جميعنا نتذكر
ان روسيا والصين استخدمتها حق نقض الفيتو
في ازاءه مشروع قرار مماثل في ال7 من
فبراير الماضي هذا القرار كان يعاقب
النظام السوري بسبب استخدام السلاح
الكيميائي كما اثبتت لجنه التحقيقات
المشتركه من الامم المتحده ومنظمه حذر
السلاح الكيميائي في ثلاث حالات يعاقب
النظام بوقف تصدير المروحيات وكذلك عدد من
المسؤولين وضباط النظام الذين يعتقد انهم
مسؤولين بشكل مباشر عن هذه الجمات بعقوبات
تشمل حضر السفر وتجميد الاموال على الارجح
لن يذهب مجلس الامن في هذا الاتجاه ول
مؤشرات على ذلك حتى الان جمال انتظار ذلك
مراد هاشم مراسل الجزيره من نيويورك شكرا
جزيلا لك ونتحول الان الى غازي عنتاب
ودكتور مازر مازن قواره سيده مازن دكتور
مازن ما هي حصيله المعلومات المتوفره
لديكم من خان شيكون حتى
الان ارقام الشهداء ارتفعت هذا المساء حسب
احصائيات مديريه صحه ادلب الى 70 شهيد
واكثر من
400 مصاب الى الى هذه اللحظه الاعداد في
تزايد عدد كبير من الاصابات لا تزال على
اجهزه التنفس الصناعي في مشافي الداخل
السوري وعدد ايضا من المصابين انتقلوا الى
تركيا بسبب عدم قدره المشافي على استيعاب
العدد الهائل
للاصابات وهي وهؤلاء المصابين يعالجون
الان في تركيا والعدد وعدد الشهداء مرجح
للازدياد اذا حتى الان 70 شهيد كما ذكرت
دكتور في
كندا جون سيرون استاذ القانون الدولي
دكتور الان ما هو ذلك التكييف القانوني
الدولي لاستخدام الغازات الكيميائيه في
مثل هذه الحاله هل نحن بصددها حيث يعني
يتضح ان كما هو واضح ان مدنيين بينهم نساء
واطفال يشكلون النسبه الاكبر من هؤلاء
الضحايا واخر عدد وصل حتى الان حوالي 70
شخصا سقطوا جراء هذه الاسلحه الكيميائيه
التي وقعت
عليهم يعني
دعم استخدام الاسلحه الكيمياويه هو خرق
سافر للقانون الدولي وخصه عندما يكون
المستهدف هم المدنيون هناك بالتاكيد
الكثير من الاسئله الكثير من العمات
الاستفهام
مازالت مطروحه خاصه عندما تم استخدام هذه
الاسلحه قبل فتره قبل سنوات تحديدا في
وطبعا نعلم ان سوريا في ذلك الوقت انضمت
الى المعاهده
الدوليه القد بحضر استخدام الاسلحه
الكيميائيه اذا اي استخدام بعد تلك السنه
لهذه الاسلحه يعد خرقا سافرا لهذه
الاتفاقيه ايضا
وهناك ايضا تجريم لاستخدام هذه الاسلحه من
قبل المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وبالتاكيد
هناك ك امكانيه الاعتبار هذا الان ايضا
كجري حرب وهل بالامكان ايضا وضع محكمه
خاصه بسوريا خاصه بالجرائم التي تم
اقترافها ضد المدنيين اذا بالتاكيد نحن
نتحدث عن جرائم ضد الانسانيه وسنرى ما هي
الامكانيه المتاحه لمتابعه
ومسائله الجنات قد تكون هناك خيارات محليه
اقليميه واخرى الدوليه طيب دكتور مازن
كواره حسب الاعراض التي شهدت على المصابين
ما هو التشخيص المرجح لنوع ذلك السلاح
الكيماوي الذي استخدم في القصف هل تؤيدون
ايضا ما قيل عن استخدام غاز الاعصاب
السارين وليس
الكلور من المؤكد ان السلاح المستخدم لم
يكن سلاح الكلور على الاطلاق السلاح
المستخدم والغاز المستخدم هو غاز من
مشتقات مركبات الفوسفور العضويه
التي السارين هو احدها وال هوو السلاح
المعروف
ب تواجده لدى قوات النظام السوري ف يرجح
استخدام السارين ولكن بدون تعيين تحليل
العينات من المرضى ومن
ارض ساحه الجريمه لا يمكن تحديد بالضبط ما
هو السلاح ولكن هو من مشتقات مركبات
الفوسفور الاضويه دور ي تحديد نوع الس حت
هذ اللحظه نقف
عند سؤالا اخر وهو انتم كاطباء ومنظمات
اغاثه طبيه كيف تفسرون ايضا تعرضكم في
المستشفيات والمراكز الطبيه لعمليات قصب
الغاز هل تقومون باي نشاطات لتوثيق هذه
الجرائم قبل ان تتلاشى الادله
عليها من المؤكد منظماتنا تقوم ب ما ما ما
يجب عليها
لتوثيق هذا هذه الاستهدافات لقد تعرضت
المشافي في ال5 من اذار المنصرم وفي بدايه
هذا الشهر واليوم ايضا للاستهداف المباشر
في في ال5 من من شهر اذار تعرضت مشفى
لاستشهاد الدكتور علي درويش رحمه الله
ومريضه الذي كان على طاوله العمليات في في
مشفى اللا طامن
اليوم المصابين تم اخذ العينات منهم
وتم وتم ذلك بشكل احترافي كما كما تم
تدريب الكادر الطبي على على ذلك وننتظر في
القريب العاجل نتائج هذه التحليل لهذه
العينات ولكننا من المؤكد بناء على
الاعراض ان هذا ما رايناه هو تسمم بمركبات
الفوسفور العضويه وغالبا غز ساري طيب
دكتور جون سيروم في كندا برايك ما الذي
يحول دون ان ترسل منظمات دوليه معنيه فرقه
مختصه للتحقيق فيما يحدث هل يجوز ترك هذا
الامر لمؤسسات الاغاثه
المحليه
بالتاكيد هناك كما تعلمون
تحديات سياسيه وامنيه تواجه هذه الفرق فرق
التحقيق ونعلم انه من الضروري القيام بهذه
التحقيقات هناك فريق موجود في جنيف وهو
مسؤوليه جمع الادله الدامغه لمتابعه اي
جهه تقف خلف اي جرائم ضد الانسانيه
ومسؤوليه ومهمه هذا الفريق تشكيل واعداد
ملف متكامل بكل الوثائق
والادله نعم هناك بعض الصعاب ومع ذلك
راينا بعض المتابعات التي انطلقت في دول
اخرى مثلا في النمسه وفي دول الاخرى
انطلقت مساطر قضائيه ضد الجناد وضد من يقف
وراء هذه الهجمات الكيميائيه واتمنى ان
تتغير الظروف من يبادر دكتور جون ما الذي
سيبادر من الذي سيقدم ذلك يعني تعود
النظام السوري على الافلات من العقاب في
ما ارتكب سابقا من جرائم مماثله لاسباب
تتعلق بالحسابات السياسيه الدوليه الان ما
هي تلك الاجراءات الواجب اتخاذها فعلا
لياخذ القانون الدولي
مجراه
من صعب جدا نقوم باي شيء قبل نهايه الصراع
نحن لا نتحدث عن فتره ما بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه حينما تم
معاقبه المجرمين في المانيا انذاك اذا
الوضع مختلف بشكل كبير نحن مازلنا في
منطقه حرب و ليس
هناك من مخرج عسكري لهذه الحرب وليس لاي
قوه عظمى الان القدره على انهاء وحسم
الحرب اذا من الصعب جدا ان نحسم في هذا
الامر الان الاجراءات ما زالت متعثره كما
قلت هناك معوقات سياسيه وامنيه تحول
دون دون القيام بالعمل المطلوب في هذا
الصدد لمحاكمه الجناد اذا قد يكون من
الضروري علينا ان ننتظر الى غايه انتهاء
هذا النزاع وهذا الصراع حتى نقوم بمتابعه
ومحاسبه الجنات يجب على
مختلف الاطراف
ان تتلاف هكذا هجمات ولكن من جهه اخرى
اعتقدوا ان روسيا
ستكون م لعدم استخدام حق الفيتو في هكذا
مناسبه جون سيرون استاذ القانون الدولي في
جامعه وينزر في كندا شكرا لك شكرا كذلك
للدكتور مازن كواره المدير الاقليميه
لمنظمه الاطباء السوريين
الامريكيين كركوك وما تثيره من جدال لا
يتوقف الا ليبدا من جديد وبزخم اكبر هي
موضوع ملفنا التالي مع عثمان اي فرح